qu'est ce qu'il ne fallait pas rater est
ce que vous êtes posé cette question là
george miller parce que c'est un enjeu
aussi de reprendre ce film qui est un
film légendaire un film culte pour
beaucoup de gens dont je suis comme tout
ce qu'il ne fallait pas rater en
reprenant cette cette histoire alors
c'était 30 ans plus tard donc tout a
changé le monde a changé de style in
changer le langage qui s'il n'a changé
oui les notre façon de lire les films a
changé oui mais en même temps
donc là il n'y a rien qui va contre la
loi de la physique donc tout était vrai
y'a pas d'hommes qui veulent donc
c'était très dur
les vrais gens des vrais véhicules est
dans le vrai désert donc c'était long
mais bon de raccorder les petits bouts
mais on a réussi on a survécu
l'armée adresses dates weight loss d'al
ahly qui ne m'a jamais fait porter une
robe qui peser moins de 30 kg lg ou de
galles longtemps c'était très lourd
hercules te désire donc il se dit si
bien dans cette seule cgt il fallait que
je chausse 45 kg pour faire ce qu'ils
voulaient que je fasse un point sur sa
frange non formés plus light
il me dit ça fait déjà huit neuf heures
on travaille et on était tous en sueur
qui ce palais encore tourné quelque
chose s'il me dit il m'a dit de tenir à
l'endroit
16h45 des cours ou en somalie try to joy
of thee oh sees de courir mais là haut
up était tellement lourde que je suis
resté coincé à certains endroits il a
fallu précoce à venir une grue pour les
dacquois ya la ville de câbles je ne
sais quoi de barres de fer
il a cherché qui venait me chercher je
trouvais ces quelques millions d'animaux
à la ds les mines de la lumière dépêchez
vous la lumière me déplacer avec un
autre pas c'était un défi physique elle
était hier soir la projection de votre
film emmanuelle bercot et votre et
mathieu votre votre émotion mon cher
rohde était littéralement palpable à la
fin de la projection regarder ces
quelques images
laurent weil je crois que l'équipe du
film est en train d'arriver
l'équipe du film est en train d'arriver
antoine très très en retard donc on m'a
demandé de ne pas faire d'une table où
tom hardy donc qu'est-ce que je vais
faire une interview de tom hardy lionel
team sui voilà il en train de signer des
autographes
tôt mardi que vous voyez des tons
directs tom tom tom
est-ce que mad max parle france
attention pas un français même
maintenant c'est vers vous je me tourne
mails bercot parce que très vite à 22
heures 4h on a le premier tweet sur
votre film je vous lis la tête haute ce
film d'ouverture à cannes la sociologie
d'un dardenne la subtilité d'un mad max
est ce que ça vous quand vous le prêt
des premiers bien ou pas bien je crois
je comprends pas ces gentils et méchants
vous l'analyse auriez comment un darden
plutôt gentil taux positifs un magma
c'est plutôt positif c'est un tweet
super sympa daerden plus mad max égal
emmanuelle bercot pierre belloche
à court je le vois que des femmes
oui le sens qu'aujourd'hui mad max
risque de tout écraser miron d'un soir
vous êtes l'un des plus grands
mannequins au monde et vous vous
retrouvez à cannes je sais que vous avez
déjà joué dans des séries américaines
mais est ce que ça vous donne des idées
de des envies de cinéma d'être ici sait
jamais mais à l'heure actuelle je
profite de cannes je suis ici pour les
glaces magnum vous savez oui mais on en
consomme tous les jours à trop regarder
notre guide vous êtes à côté d'eux adel
et de tard deux spécialistes de cannes
puisque c'est ici que vous avez été
révélés tous les deux tard vous
souhaitez en 2009 avec un prophète de
jacques audiard et vous adèle c'était en
2013 avec le la palme d'or la vida
d'elle l'année dernière vous allez bien
très bien et vous oui vous êtes content
d'être là ouais bien sûr on est hyper
heureux vous avez envie donner ce qu'il
vous d'accord
senna
m